[Music]
we asked the questions i'm just curious
i mean what brought you all into us
[Music]
long story a lot of twists
no doubt
no doubt
i'm nicole steele with the department of
justice in a city of 620 000 bpd cops
reported over 300 000 pedestrian stops
in the last five years
you guys have locked up and beat on so
many people we can't get 12 in a box
we're willing to trust with a composite
could there ever be a moment where a
police officer performed their job in
such a manner that you would agree with
the finding that he should be fired for
abusive behavior or brutality sure has
it ever happened
we're doing our jobs what do people want
for us to stop policing they want us to
do it without the collateral damage you
know what the baltimore cops who don't
have complaints they're doing every day
they sure as hell ain't police and you
can't just blame the cops
we serve the politicians who thrive on
being tough on crime and when they
reinstated me they put me in a unit made
up of a bunch of the biggest crooks in
the whole goddamn department these men
right here my detectives we do things by
the book
mr the madness i'm living
the drug war justifies a lot mr demand
this is a dysfunctional police
department with a culture that looks at
accountability as a four-letter word i
told you weeks ago about a federal
investigation there's always a rumor of
a federal investigation this [ __ ] never
happens it's baltimore [ __ ] been going
on for a long while we just followed the
leader i'm not going to lose my job over
this
around
we built this machine where half the
damn country took a part with money and
power chew up the other half i didn't
have anything to begin with
watch it work i feel like you got
i teach young kids to be good
honest cops
rush this up to them
i'm not a dirty cop
mrs
[Music]
you